[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a russian-american dark
fantasy science fiction film called
branded spoilers ahead watch out and
take care
a russian kid named misha looks up at
the sky and sees stars shifting into a
cow-shaped constellation when the cow
looks down at him misha wakes up
realizing he was dreaming some seconds
later he gets hit by a bolt of lightning
and falls unconscious a crowd gathers
around him as a woman examines his body
after a few soft slaps he regains
consciousness and the woman comments
that he will live an interesting life
the scene shifts to 20 years later over
the years misha has proven himself to be
a talented marketing executive he has
partnered with an american businessman
bob gibbons and made considerable
progress in his career one day at an
awards ceremony bob's niece abby
introduces herself to misha she praises
his work and seems to be interested in
him after the ceremony bob and misha are
in his office discussing abby's presence
bob wants her to return to america and
is annoyed she won't listen to him he
has also sensed a budding relationship
between her and misha but is strictly
against it misha promises not to get
involved with her for bob's sake then we
are introduced to a billionaire
marketing specialist mr pascal he
arranges a meeting with fast food
company executives on his private
polynesian island pascal has a brilliant
idea to make their part of the industry
more profitable they plan to change
people's perception of beauty and make
being fat the new beauty standard in the
following scene abby and misha are on
their way to a studio abby has invited
him because she needs help with the
marketing side of a project she is
working on a popular brand is about to
broadcast an extreme makeover reality tv
show they plan to recruit an overweight
woman with potential and make her
undergo surgery after the procedure the
woman will be slim and will fit into the
current beauty standard the idea has
potential hence misha takes on the job
but what he doesn't know is that the
marketing guru pascal has an ulterior
motive behind funding the project a
flashback shows us how misha discovered
his talent for marketing a few years ago
shortly after the fall of the soviet
union he worked at a shop he helped the
owner with different tactics of
marketing that made him a lot of money
however when misha asked for a raise he
was kicked out immediately that is when
he met bob initially he thought bob was
an american spy who wanted him to work
against the russian government later he
realized that bob didn't want info on
the government but the common people he
wanted to form an american russian
advertising agency which was only
possible with a russian man's help and
so misha's career as a marketer spy
began over the next 15 years he designed
the first russian campaigns for a host
of western brands one of which is a fast
food chain called the burger it is one
of the businesses supported by pascal
back in the present abby and misha spend
more time together for work according to
misha modern marketing was invented by
the politician vladimir lenin and
communism is the first truly global
brand impressed by his profound thought
abby wonders how he is still single
misha tries his best to refrain from
being attracted to her but he cannot
help it one day when they are stuck in a
long traffic jam things get steamy they
do not realize the inside of the car is
visible through the window and get
caught in the act by bob he interrupts
them and punches misha in the face for
doing something he was exclusively told
not to starting the next day the
broadcast of the reality tv show begins
they hire a chubby woman named veronica
to be the only contestant the show
instantly becomes a hit as people are
eager to see how she looks after the
surgeries one day before the procedure
veronica gets cold feet she sends a
video message to misha and abby saying
she doesn't want to go through the
procedure anymore but she doesn't have
the option to back out this far into the
game the surgery goes well much to misha
and abby's delight they celebrate by
dancing and drinking hoping to see a new
veronica tomorrow however the next day
they get horrible news veronica never
came out of anesthesia and has fallen
into a coma abby panics and blames
herself for the mishap they treated a
woman like a play doll and are facing
the consequences the media and the
public who had been following the show
closely are enraged in the moment of
emergency misha becomes the scapegoat
for the company he and abby are arrested
for fraud and thrown into jail it is
then revealed that the failed show was
all a part of pascal's plan he wanted to
change the beauty standard to fat hence
he showed people the disadvantages of
trying to be thin and created an
environment of mass hysteria the panic
is so intense that people start
believing they are doing something wrong
by always trying to lose weight a week
later misha is being bailed out by bob
in turn for the bail abby is made to go
back to the us and never see misha again
after getting out misha immediately
calls her but she is already at the
airport terminal following that he goes
to meet bob and accuses him of planning
the failure of the show in another
flashback we see misha writing his first
report as a marketer he chooses his
former boss to be his first subject in
the report he paints him as a drug
dealer and a con man misha thought it
was just for analytics but it wasn't the
news was published which eventually
caused the man to be killed by the
protesting public after the casualty
misha went to the remains of the shop
and saw what his story had done to it at
that moment he realized that with the
power of marketing he can not only build
a brand but change the entire world he
thinks bob was behind the unsuccessful
surgery which he planned to separate
abby and himself however bob laughs at
the absurdity claiming he doesn't have
time and money to spend on something so
worthless they go out to a bar where the
two get into an altercation yet again
suddenly bob has a heart failure that
kills him instantly misha is left all
alone with no will to return to the
business
after bob's death misha disappeared
six years later abby returns to russia
and starts looking for him following the
leads one after another she ends up on a
farm and finds misha working as a
shepherd in the middle of nowhere he
doesn't want to return to the city
because his job has always harmed people
first his former boss then veronica abby
who still loves him decides to stay with
him for a few days one night misha
dreams of the same cow that he had seen
years ago the animal describes a ritual
to every minute detail and asks misha to
perform it even after waking up he
remembers everything he was told in the
dream the details are so clear to him
that he blindly builds a structure out
of wood then he brings one of his red
cows to the structure and sacrifices it
for the ritual the next morning he
bathes in the cow's ashes and completes
it but by the end he falls unconscious
due to exhaustion over the years that he
was on hiatus the world has changed
drastically fast food chains have taken
over russia and being fat has become the
new fabulous oversized models toys
superheroes and actors are the ones
winning in society the burger restaurant
especially has reached the highest form
of success and has made the public
addicted to its products after finding
misha unconscious on the field abby
brings him back to moscow he is glad
that she helped him but is in bad
condition he sees a creature by abby's
head that is only visible to him at home
misha is met with another surprise when
he is told that he fathered a baby six
years ago his name is robert and he is
also addicted to fast food misha sees
several creatures tagging from robert's
neck but doesn't tell abby an entire day
passes but his hallucination doesn't go
away the next afternoon the family goes
on a walk misha notices that the
creature tagging along with robert is
the symbol of the burger company the
company's branch has a massive creature
on top of it that feeds off of its
customer similarly every company has its
own tag that is manipulating people into
buying things from them it turns out
that after the ritual misha was given a
unique power to see how the public is
being manipulated for the next few days
everything goes well abby robert and
misha live like a happy family but misha
knows that he cannot let his son be
manipulated alongside millions of
innocent people one day he loses his
cool and starts breaking things at the
house abby catches him in the act and
flies back to america with robert she
also leaves misha a message asking him
to be gone when they return from the
trip when left alone with no hope misha
joins a creative advertising company
this time with the motive to end what
the brand started as a first step he
arranges a meeting with chinese
businessman looking to establish a
vegetarian restaurant chain dim song he
bluntly tells them that the idea won't
work because people are obsessed with
hamburgers at the moment but he also
suggests an alternative way to market
the product that is to destroy the
competition they spread the news that
meat in burgers is not safe with the
recent new disease going around people
are quick to believe it the company then
advertises their new product called the
meat tester it is a device that checks
the quality of meat instantly but the
politicians who are used to profiting
off of the restaurants do not allow the
campaign to flourish the health minister
even eats a hamburger on live television
to show people that it is safe the
chinese businessmen go into a huge loss
but misha is satisfied with the results
of the project then the same week the
health minister dies from an unknown
cause people instantly assume it's
because of the burger he ate when they
start to panic and look for a healthier
alternative to burgers several dim song
restaurants are built in the city just
when misha thinks he won he notices dim
song's tag getting bigger he realizes
that as long as people can advertise
they will continue to manipulate the
public soon dim song gets so big that
its tag forms an egg it hatches giving
birth to a dragon-like flying creature
the creature attacks the burger's tag
and eats it indicating the company's
downfall the next day it is revealed
that the burger's stocks have taken a
plunge pascal holds another meeting with
the ceos of the food chains he supported
he tells them that he can do nothing
about the companies because they are too
far gone suddenly a bolt of lightning
strikes him making him disappear
within a month or two all the brands
that pascal supported go bankrupt this
also gives rise to an unexpected outcome
people all around the globe have started
protesting to ban advertisements of all
kinds abby and robert watch the news and
see misha on it he is asked by the
reporter what he thinks will be the
president's decision but he doesn't give
them a definite answer later that day
misha is alone in his office sending
abby a voicemail and asking for
forgiveness suddenly she appears in
front of him at the same time a group of
protesters barge into the advertisement
office and start attacking the employees
the couple tries to run away but misha
is caught and beaten even though he also
supports the idea of banning
advertisements he is about to be killed
when the protesters are informed that
the president has agreed to do as they
say over the next few days every
billboard from the streets of moscow is
removed misha wakes up in a hospital bed
with abby and his son by his side at the
same time veronica who had been in a
coma for almost seven years also wakes
up the movie ends as she wanders into
the streets to see a skyline free of
billboards subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching